let's uh bring in dr mehmet oz he's the
host of the dr oz show he's a
cardiologist and he's got a new hat he's
now a political candidate to be the
republican
uh running in pennsylvania for the u.s
senate dr oz good morning to you good
morning good morning steve let me just
explain why i moved from just a few
blocks from where you are making my show
with great joy uh into the political
ring i i actually feel we're in a great
crisis and like you've been watching
this and covert really broke the country
in some ways and i feel our values are
under attack so i've asked the voters of
pennsylvania to consider me for their
senator for the united states uh and i'm
going to serve america in his time of
need the best of my ability we need
better solutions they're out there we
ought to stop shaming and silencing and
bullying and canceling people with ideas
that are different than ours especially
when they're good ideas we saw that play
out plenty in covid and i gotta say
medicine when you cannot see say what
you see people die
so we ought to be able to do at least
that as as dr brian was just
articulating with our management of
covid let's just get clear about what
we're actually experiencing and so we
don't wander down a path of making the
same mistakes we made the first time
around dr oz
we're all ready to move on with our
lives and
people in new york are worried that
these schools are going to make our kids
get manned uh get vaccinated some of
them don't want their kids to have the
shot yet especially those who whose kids
have already had covet
you have all these people that are
losing their jobs we see what's
happening with inflation um is it safe
for us to move on with our lives are you
worried about this variant what's your
advice
i'm not worried about the variant there
are lots of mutations on the variant 32
of them are on the spike protein so i
understand why we need to watch it
carefully but we have no evidence that
it's more of a problem than delta
variant and we have no evidence that
it's resistant to vaccines and we don't
have any evidence that it's more
dangerous to us so what are the criteria
by which we would for example declare a
state of emergency in new york and what
are the criteria to lift that state of
emergency we went through this remember
two weeks to bend the curve i was with
you that metastasized in this
overarching authoritarianism that
started to destroy our culture our
beliefs our values and then you start to
train people to be docile to be chattel
to just follow the rules and follow the
orders even though the people making the
rules oftentimes don't really know what
to do so they just make rules right so
it doesn't work we've been down this
path and to that point uh yesterday in
your rollout video that you had you
released something on social media i saw
you said covet has shown us our system
is broken washington got it wrong they
took away our freedoms and that
ultimately is what you want to try to
fix how do you fix that
well one is transparency but most
importantly we got to empower americans
if you take charge of your own health
you reduce the complications of coba
that's something you can do i spent my
whole career empowering people i powered
my patients my viewers on the show i'll
do it now for the citizens of
pennsylvania for the whole country and
i've taken on big pharma so that the
only data you see is not just big pharma
data i've taken on big text same story
they control the narrative so they tell
you the stories you're supposed to
believe same fights i've had with
agrichemical companies i've got the
scars to prove it we talked about some
of these battles i'll keep waging them i
cannot be bought and you have people
talking about this stuff honestly it's
uncomfortable for moneyed interest but
it's what has to happen in america so
doctor oz a couple of things number one
you realize if you question anthony
thatcher you question science so how
dare you uh uh question anything i want
you to apologize to science uh number
two is i believe and i could be wrong on
this
that you were totally befuddled by the
reaction to hydrogoxy core
hydroxychloroquine you were just asking
questions and the blowback the magnitude
of it was shocking to you as somebody
who came up in the medical profession
and does that still every day you're
asking the same questions but now you're
asking those medical questions in a
political environment
and you were just almost
taken aback to the point where you
knocked knocked back a little you had to
recalibrate
your your remarks is that is that
correct
when you mix politics and medicine you
get politics what we witnessed not just
with uh hydroxychloroquine but
many other solutions that have been
offered subsequently is that there's a
single perspective that's allowed to get
vaccinated listen i think one of the
greatest accomplishments of america is
that we gave the world the mrna vaccines
through president trump's operational
warp speed i'm so happy that we were
able to do that and i got vaccinated and
i believe in vaccines i don't believe in
mandates and i also don't believe it's
the only path to success from day one
we've argued that doctors do not send
patients home with just a prescription
or a piece of paper but then with a
diagnosis we send you home with a game
plan about how to cure yourself how to
make yourself better to empower you
right in kobe we said you know go home
if your lips turn blue call us you might
need to get hospitalized that's not good
enough and when you have doctors around
the world offering the best solutions
possible during the fog of war we ought
to at least listen to them to this day
we have not done adequate quality
clinical trials to test most of these
products we had a pill approved
yesterday by the fda and listen
carefully this pill from merck was
available before that pandemic started
it was here for more than two years we
just yesterday had the fda panel say you
know it saves lives we ought to approve
it finally doctors for the first time
have a pill to give patients who have a
diagnosis of covert we should have done
much much better than this but we
couldn't ask the questions yeah because
it's too political hey uh so you know
when it comes to the senate race in
pennsylvania you obviously have enormous
name recognition because you've been on
television for a very long time oprah
winfrey introduced us to you back in the
day
uh have you have you talked to oprah
have you heard from oprah about running
for senate
of course i spoke with oprah she's my my
partner on the show she's been a huge
mentor fairest woman i know i told her
that my interests were in politics she
listened she's very thoughtfully about
it
she said do you know do what your heart
says to do
i i just i want to run this race to
address the major issues we face in
america and the prognosis is good i feel
more upbeat about america today than i
have in a long time because i've seen
the solutions out there they're
fantastic but they're being suffocated
so i'm running to make sure that those
great ideas see the light of day that's
what we've always done as a country
right and here's the pledge i'm going to
be your public servant we can
reinvigorate america with these good
ideas if we listen to each other and
this is important we got to start seeing
the divine spark in each other again
we're not we're not the enemy of each
other are you ready for this race i mean
you are
loved by everyone in america and you've
decided to run as a republican tell us
about the thought process what your
conversations were like with your family
and to leave such a a big job making a
lot of money to go into politics
well ainslie thanks for bringing the
family issue up it was the most
important part of the decision because
you do take your whole family down the
path so my youngest uh son oliver who's
been on this show i just started medical
school at columbia so i figured when the
youngest one was sort of out of the
process i could go out and do what i
wanted to do for a while which is to
serve our nation lisa as you know is a
strong strong one best thing i ever did
was meet her here in philadelphia and
marry her 36 years ago and so i feel
blessed to have her by my side and i
tell you one thing she does set me
straight
in my house the prosecution never rests
right it's interesting
all right all right dr oz look forward
to talking to you it's uh it's going to
be a whirlwind i look forward to get
ready for the knives
i'm looking forward god bless you all
slings and arrows
in his business they're scalpels right
just saying all right thank you very
much all the best god bless you good
luck
i don't like to say good luck why do i
said that yesterday and today i don't
believe in luck i believe blessings god
bless you bless him bless him god bless
you okay there you go wherever he is